Will Gold remain an important form
of money?
Or are cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
set to overtake it?
That was the subject of a Soho forum
debate held on Tuesday, July
26, at the Mises
Institute in Auburn, Alabama,
as part of Mises University
Week, an annual event attended
by more than 80 students from
around the country.
Keith Weiner, CEO of Monetary
Metals, defended the resolution,
"Gold will remain an important form
of money in the 21st century."
Weiner took the position that gold
is poised to hold on to the monetary
status it's enjoyed for the past
5000 years, and
that its recent performance only
confirms why.
Pierre Rochard, co-host of the
Bitcoin for Advisers podcast,
took the negative, arguing that the
technological advantages of Bitcoin
will make it the preferred medium
of exchange in a post dollar
world.
This debate was moderated by Soho
Forum director Gene Epstein.
Without any further ado,
I want to remind you of the
resolution.
Gold. Gold will remain
an important form of money in the
21st century.
Please vote initially
yes, no, or undecided
on the resolution here to
defend the resolution.
Keith Wiener.
Keith, please come to the stage.
Taking.
Taking the negative on the
resolution.
Pierre Rochard.
Pierre, please come to the stage.
Okay.
I hope you've all voted yes or no
or undecided on the resolution.
Connor, please close
the voting.
Keith, you have 15 minutes to
defend the resolution.
Take it away, Keith.
If this debate
were about which asset
is better at skyrocketing,
also crashing.
Then I would shake my
opponent's hand, concede
and walk off the stage
because bitcoin is obviously
superior at skyrocketing
and also crashing.
However, that was not the debate.
The debate is gold will remain money
in the important form of money in
the 21st century.
Ladies and gentlemen, our
esteemed moderators Gene Epstein.
My honored opponent here,
Rochard.
In a way, this debate is
a bit unfair
because gold has been doing what it
does for 5000 years,
and the proposition is that it's
going to continue doing for the next
hundred years what it's been doing
for 5000 years in
a certain sense.
Good luck to debunking
that or arguing against that.
But
there's a lot more to be said,
obviously, about
money and excuse me
and how all this works.
So.
We live in a system where we have
a failing dollar.
I don't think that's very
controversial in this audience.
Some audiences I speak to, you
say that people like what?
And then the room breaks into
pandemonium.
But the dollar is designed.
This is a feature, not a bug.
I'll keep referring to this concept
of a feature, not a bug.
The dollar is designed to go down.
The Fed on its Web site says
2% per year, which they define
as price stability.
I wonder what Orwell would be saying
about that.
So it's designed to go down to a
steady rate.
Why?
As a as a free boon to
borrowers, if you borrow
money and then the dollar's going
down, then what you owe the return
of is falling in value.
The longer the term of the loan,
the greater the fall, the easier
the burden on the debtors.
And that is how the system,
if I can use the word rigged,
is rigged.
Unfortunately, the dollar doesn't
do as they would wish, doesn't
do as their theory would predict,
and it isn't steady
or stable.
It is not a simple mechanism for
robbing Peter to pay Paul.
Peter being the lender and the
other. So every trade has two sides.
And there's Peter over here is a
saver who's lending in savings to
something and expecting to get that
back with interest.
Well, he's the one who's screwed
when the dollar goes down.
And then, Paul, over here, the
borrower is the one who wins when
the dollar goes down. Unfortunately
for Paul,
it isn't a steady,
linear,
monotonic, would be the term,
progression of going down and
has wicked volatility to it.
And as we see right now, the
dollar's going up, not down,
which means the borrowers are
finding that their burden of debt
is increasing, not decreasing.